filmmaking is a tricky business it's a
long journey from the script to the
screen and the lots of great and not so
great scenes get left on the cutting
room floor costing the studio time and
money he has a look at some of our
favorite films whose deleted scenes came
at a high price
creatively and financially world war Z's
darker final acts World War Z didn't
discriminate spensive scene or to this
movie's entire third act was gutted and
replaced in post-production in the
theatrical ending the movie concluded
with Brad Pitt's Jerry Lane wandering
around a research laboratory and
discovering the scientific solution to
all the world's zombie problems but in
the original shoot of things were
supposed to be a lotta grimmer for our
hero before the revisions Jerry and his
sidekicks Egon would have made it to
Russia to do a blockbuster sighs a
battle with zombies and discover a
method of undead to defeat the
old-fashioned way but there was still
trouble on the home front as his wife
and children were in North America and
she turned to prostitution to provide
for her family and ultimately shacked up
with a former colleague played by
Matthew Fox this would have culminated
in Pitt's character questing across
Siberia to make way to his now estranged
wife leaving room for what would have
been a full-on trilogy of World War Z
films but the studio wanted a happier
ending for the film and brought in a
bunch of new creatives to rewrite and
reshoot at the third act and everything
else including almost all the fox's
parts were left on the cutting room
floor never to see the light of day
not only did Paramount lose the money
they'd already spent for the clipped
scenes but the reshoots ended up costing
a whopping 25 million dollars as well
and the VAT friends as what you call a
pricey pivot rogue scenes in x-men Days
of Future past with it's crazy
time-travel plots x-men Days of Future
past is packed with familiar faces but
unfortunately that means limited screen
time for some of our favorite characters
including Anna Paquin's rogue The True
Blood actress spent a week filming
several elaborate scenes for the 2014
blockbuster alongside fellow x-men vets
but none of it wound up in the finished
film director Bryan Singer told
Entertainment Weekly through the edits
process the sequence became extraneous
like many things in the editing process
it was an embarrassment of riches and it
was just one of the things I had to go
after fan outcry singer and 20th Century
Fox released a raga cut of the film on
DVD restoring 17 minutes of previously
cut footage that included Paquin
sequences the original tragic ending of
Little Shop of Horrors if all that
Ghana's director Frank Oz and a
screenwriter Howard Ashman had initially
planned this 1986 adaptation of the
Broadway musical wouldn't have ended
quite as happily the pair intended to
use the ending from the stage version of
Little Shop of Horrors with Audrey -
eating Audrey and Seymour and
terrorizing the world but test audiences
hated it as Records to Entertainment
Weekly for every musical number there
was applause they loved it it was
fantastic until we killed our two leads
and then the theater became a
refrigerator an ice box in order to get
the movie released they needed better
audience approval so the elaborate 23
minute sequence which cost two reported
five million dollars was scrapped and
the new ending was shot with the two
leads alive and well though a
black-and-white version of the original
ending was included on a 1998 DVD
release full-color footage was finally
included in a director's cut edition
blu-ray in 2012 the Jitterbug dance
number from The Wizard of Oz the Wicked
Witch uses a lot of different tactics to
try to stop a Dorothy and her friends in
The Wizard of Oz but one never made it
into the final version of the film in
the lost jitterbug sequence Dorothy the
Scarecrow Tin Man and Cowardly Lion
traveled through the haunted woods only
to be attacked by evil bugs that caused
them to break out in song and dance also
a popular dance style at the time the
jitterbug was actually a remnant of an
older version of the script that was
tossed out the whole number costs about
80,000 dollars and took five weeks to
shoot but it was cut when producers
decided the film was too long though the
actual footage was destroyed composer
Harold Arlen captured a dress rehearsal
of the number on video
later included as an extra on the DVD
version of the film maybe the original
footage will turn up in a studio storage
space like Dorothy's old ruby slippers
did returning to Krypton in Superman
Returns before TC and Warner Brothers
decided to reboot the Superman franchise
yet again in 2013 with Zack Snyder at
the helm Bryan Singer's 2006 entry
starring Brandon Ralph as a Man of Steel
a flew into theaters with fairly mixed
reviews Superman Returns also nearly
arrived with a completely different
opening sequence while the basic plot of
the film deals of Superman's return to
earth after a five-year absence singer
shot a worthless visually stunning
five-minute opening sequence with Ralph
Superman visiting what was left of his
home planet Krypton the scene which cost
an estimated 10 million dollars is slow
and contemplative rather than bombastic
and exciting
maybe that's why producers ultimately
had singer cut it the scene was finally
released as an extra on the 2011
Superman anthology blu-ray sets further
dividing critics and fans on the one-off
superhero flick Eric Stoltz is scenes
from Back to the Future as most Back to
the Future fans know Eric Stoltz was
originally cast as Marty McFly the puffy
vest wearing teenager sent back to 1955
in a souped-up DeLorean director Robert
Zemeckis initially wanted to hire
Michael J Fox but his family tight
shooting schedule was too demanding at
the time and he hired Stoltz instead
five weeks into filming at the Marcus
and producer Steven Spielberg knew they
needed to replace Stoltz because he just
wasn't funny enough Zemeckis and
Spielberg had quickly negotiated with
Universal to replace Stoltz with Fox
adding a reported three million dollars
to the film's budget and extra time onto
its shooting schedule soon Fox was on
set at the Twin Pines mall shooting with
Christopher Lloyd and the rest of course
is history thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to